many of us are prey to addictive
behaviors which we know run contrary to
our deeper interests but which we find
ourselves entirely unable to desist from
at Key moments let's pick three of these
bulimia porn addiction and alcoholism
we will appreciate as soon as we come
out of the tunnel of addiction that we
have neglected our interests and harmed
ourselves and yet we are at a loss as to
what we might do what if anything could
help
one kind of answer is this
we should try to notice when the desire
to regurgitate food or watch porn or
drink strikes us
though this might sound strange those in
the grip of addictions seldom do notice
they don't pay much attention to what
has immediately happened before their
desires strike
it doesn't occur to them that anything
has
and yet if they did look into themselves
and studied the answers very carefully
they would have an important weapon with
which to escape the downward spiral
and that's because to make another
generalization before there is ever an
addictive behavior there is always a
moment of feeling bad very very bad
about something
the triggers can be varied
a partner may not be as warm as they
should be or someone at work seems
disapproving and mean or one's been left
out perhaps not for the first time of a
social occasion
in other words the triggers for
Addictive self-harming behaviors are
rooted in such emotions as loneliness
shame a sense of unacceptability a
feeling of rejection or a belief one is
not good enough
The Addictive pattern is only a response
A Part B to a part A that we are not
used to exploring
addiction has nothing to do with loving
what one's addicted to
to do with finding relief from a prior
pain which has not been understood or
addressed
for a Time The Addictive Behavior offers
a kind of soothing and escape from an
intolerable discomfort vomiting after a
meal brings a sense of lightness porn
leads one into a series of physical
highs a state of drunkenness Stills
critical voices
the way to start to break the pattern of
addiction is simply to realize before we
have rushed to the addictive solution
that we are in trouble that we have for
whatever reason grown very sad and
hopeless about ourselves and therefore
we are in a danger zone and need help
now rather than in a few hours we have
to become better historians and
observers of our moods and aim to put a
gap in time and in mental activity
between the moment when we are hurt and
the moment when we reach for our
self-destructive solution
if we manage to slow down the process
then we should be able to wake ourselves
up from our narcotic impulses and say in
a profoundly helpful way I'm upset
just the realization that we are so is
half the battle at least I'm feeling
deeply upset and therefore I am in
danger
and from here we can ask another
extremely pertinent set of questions
what am I upset about how am I upset
we may need to close our eyes and just
sit still for a moment to let the answer
percolate from the unconscious
alternatively we might try and complete
the following sentence
I'm currently feeling upset because
it's one of the quirks of the strange
brains we all have that it can take so
long to know what we're feeling and to
understand what might have caused it
when we do start to notice our upset
then we can begin the business of
self-soothing in more fruitful ways one
side can run an arm around the other and
say in effect poor you how awful to be
feeling awful again
almost certainly in early life no one
had much sympathy or the remotest bit of
interest in our feelings of loss
self-hatred and abandonment
that's why we find it so hard to get
interested in them ourselves but we can
patch up the damage we can ask how am I
feeling about myself and what's happened
to give me that feeling
we can replace addiction with
self-compassion and understanding
no one Falls prey to addictions by
coincidence the behaviors always have
roots in an intense normally
childhood-derived sense of being a
terrible unworthy person
in summary the route to stopping
addictive behavior is to ask oneself how
one is feeling realize one is probably
feeling very bad
curious about and sympathetic to the
causes and and then ask what would be a
better Kinder way of handling this sense
of awfulness
knowing that there is room and love for
the feeling that provokes addiction is
the key to weakening the hold of and one
day overcoming what we are addicted to